دفن ضحية أخرى
وإلى الأرض التي قتلت عندما هزها
أكثر من 2000 شخص لقوا حتفهم في
أسوأ زلزال مغربي منذ أكثر من
مائة عام، وكانت معظم الوفيات في
قرى في جبال الأطلس
حيث تصدعت المنازل وانهارت في وقت متأخر من
ليلة الجمعة.
انهيار هذه المباني في
شارع جانبي هنا في الملايو، أدى إبراهيم إلى مقتل
25 شخصًا، ولا يزال ثلاثة أو أربعة
في عداد المفقودين. بيلي مدفون تحت الأنقاض
وهذا نمط يتكرر
في جميع أنحاء هذه المقاطعة ويبدو في
كثير من الأحيان أنه كان هناك نوع
من الغارات الجوية  المباني المنهارة
هنا تترك في الواقع ثقوبًا كما لو أنها
تعرضت للقنابل الروسية في
أوكرانيا، لكن هذه كانت
كارثة طبيعية للغاية، فقد
تم دفن ثلاثة أشخاص مسنين على الأقل
هنا في بقايا
الفندق الذي يقيمون فيه، كما فُقد نزيل رابع
بعد ذلك.  الزلزال اتصل سامي بوالديه
لمدة يوم ونصف ثم
رن الهاتف حتى نفدت البطارية أيضًا، أنا
هنا فقط
لأنني فقدت اثنين من
أفضل ما أملك في هذه الحياة، لقد
فقدتُ والدي وأمي.
لهم هنا يتحول حزنه إلى غضب
على الحكومة كما هو الحال مع الكثيرين
هنا ليس لديهم أي تخطيط فقط
لديهم كلمات،
إنه بالون من الكلمات
فقط لديهم
كلمات،
هذا كل ما
يصل ولكن ببطء
في السلطات القريبة من آزني أخبرني أن
27  قُتل أشخاص في الزلزال عام
1200، فقدوا منازلهم،
لذا قالت فاطمة وزوجها إنهما
عندما كانا في المنزل كانت في
الحمام
عندما
اندلعت سلسلة الانفجارات، قالوا إنه
لم يكن هناك اهتزاز للأرض، وهي
تقول ذلك  شعرت وكأن انفجار
بندقية كلاشينكوف الأوتوماتيكية
كان هذا بمثابة إحساس بأن المكان قد
ضربته الحرب، ولم يكن لديهم أي فكرة أنهم
يعانون من زلزال
ولحسن الحظ بالنسبة لهم قاموا بإجلاء
أسرهم بسرعة كبيرة ولم يكن أحد في
أسرهم  قُتل ولكن في القرية
قُتل 27 شخصًا عظيمًا، المنزل
الآن مهجور
لكن فاطمة قادت فريقًا من النساء المحليات
للعثور على الطعام والمأوى للمشردين
قبل وصول أي مساعدات، كل الطعام هنا
نتيجة التبرعات الخاصة، لا
تزال العديد من القرى هنا
ستركز عمليات الإغاثة على الطرق المعزولة التي قطعتها الانهيارات الأرضية
على الوصول إليها،
ويفكر رجال الإطفاء في البحث عن
جثث أسفل الفندق،
وكان استنتاجهم مخيبا للآمال
وسط الصدمات والبناء المحطم، ومن
الخطير للغاية إنقاذ الموتى، لذا
في الوقت الحالي سيبقى والدا سامي مدفونين
حيث هما
سام  كايلي سي إن إن في مولاي إبراهيم